that extra three minutes now to  calculate yeah it's also such an easy  line you bring the king closer and then  you give the roku one check your card of  the kingdom it's very easy you'll find  it eventually  so  what happened here earlier because it  said c2 king c3 it said it's a draw here  it's a good game  h3 is still drawing  and not only is quite insane by the way  wow i've never seen he's resigned more  lucky  more lucky and more unfair lost somehow  maxim did everything very well  yeah so he got his night stuck and then  it got got tricky he was still okay yeah  even  by margin like it was and then he did  something yeah it was a bit unfortunate  but it's good we avoided that uh  statistic of magnus losing our magazines  yeah  yeah so  that's a